all right hi everyone we are continuing
our design review for version 13.3 of
Orphan language uh related to algebra
and finite Fields right now and then
we're going to be talking about matrices
and special functions
okay where have we got to with finite
fields we wanted to look at some
um at the type setting
where do I look for uh well I guess just
open an example or or maybe go go to a
you know the finite Fields ref page
basically you just wanna
we did fix the um the stuff with uh
algebraic numbers right didn't we
we did fix that didn't we
it's on the to-do list oh no
you mean it's not fixed for this version
no
oh no
we really need that fixed
is there something we can do to make
that not as totally broken as it is
right now because it's really useless
right now really infuriatingly useless
right now I well I disagree with that
assessment but
um
just useless I mean it's just useless
what am I supposed to do with this what
am I supposed to do with it
what do I do with it well what do you
want to do with it I mean right you can
copy and paste it and and and
I mean right and and and use it as an
object right the the point of this idea
is that people got this thing that said
you know root of hash hash Ampersand and
they were very confused and this is
emphasizing that this is an exact number
with that approximate value we have you
know right how do I get the root out of
it uh what do you mean by the root I
mean that that is the root no how do I
get some representation that is clearly
um
can we please not make sure this does
not slip another version please
okay it was going to stop another
version you got to let me know
can we make sure it does not slip
another version to get the fix to this
oh
I'll work on it okay we missed 13 3
which is very disappointing let's not
miss again
all right let's look at finite Fields
here
right so you had to say right you didn't
like the plus signs that we that I had
in the subscript and you had this idea
of
um you know sort of folding everything
into
um
so that's sort of what I've implemented
right everything into the subscript into
a gray background which this may not be
exactly the right color but you know I
picked a color
um but I don't understand what was this
thing here
right so there was just a plus sign
there and you didn't like that plus sign
and so I mean I can show you what the
plus sign looked like if no no no no no
no no what
okay what does this do
this F here is yet something different
right
the fact that this F is there is just
irrelevant I mean that's just for
amusement values so to speak but then
you're using this app
as the main finite field designator
correct
and if I look up finite field
and do like an image search for finite
field
well you'll probably either see a k or a
more commonly a double struck F sub Q
I'm not finding I'm finding stupid stuff
here I'm finding GF that's what I'm
finding all over the place is GF
yeah we originally had GF but since that
we call this finite field rather than
Galway field we thought it was weird to
have a GF in the icon
what about a double struck f
we can do a double struck F but what's
the argument for for the script f
well well struck
So Adam was the one who actually created
that icon and I didn't see a reason to
change it
um can you speak to that please oh it
was a script GF
you know some um
right okay so that's what happened right
so originally we had GF where it is
common to use
script letters and then we just have
that to F but we didn't change it from
script to double struck
okay I mean that's an easy thing that's
a that's a trivial fix I know it's
important
now what font is that F going to be in
um
I I well I believe it's in
uh
well the way it's currently implemented
it's in whatever is the default font of
Graphics because right that's a graphics
with a with a text inside of it
so what do we do do we do a text here
yep and then wrap it in graphics and
that'll
right because the naturals
and then it'll be
um not uh it'll be not
not bold right
um is that bold
I I think that is what is the normal
plane all right yes yep
one's playing okay
so that's what it'll look like I think
it's better than the script right uh do
it do we want to italicize it
I don't know you tell me I I don't
particularly think so okay I think it
should be in the spirit of the other
ones like integers and rationals and
real complexes right okay yes and we
don't italicize those so yeah so it's we
should just stick with a plain s
fine
and the font this font looks okay
yep
okay all right
um and then you probably need to change
the example so you're not setting it to
be a script to f
right okay
all right that was a good catch I'm I'm
glad I asked about that
yep okay now let's come to this these
are field elements right yep
and the five is the characteristic
but I don't quite understand what's that
yes I was just confirming that five is
the characteristic
okay so this thing down here is kind of
a proxy for this whole object here
right and when you click the down you
get the whole object so I'm I'm not
understanding isn't the notation for the
field usually F sub five
yeah yes
so if we were going to put something
down here with all kinds of decorative
crud
wouldn't the most natural thing to put
there be F sub 5
it's just a lot
I know but but you've got a lot there
right now but we can't I mean so
typically double subscripts don't work I
know I know I know so we need to what's
here is really ugly yeah no I agree
we've got multiple things going on here
we've got the angle brackets
we've got
you know
then we've got that down arrow then
we've got the five
but really
the thing here you know what I would
think about doing
is in this box decorating with a
background app
but somehow have a box be be able to be
uh you know have some kind of Chevron
opener
but have the main thing visible in the
Box be the f
even if this doesn't subscript down very
much
are you with us at all here
it's Jeremy here
I was on double mute so in that case is
the F more prominent or bigger than the
five not sure how all these elements
work together so the other thing is what
you're gonna see is that the five is
going to be raised to some number you
know sometimes you want to show those
two numbers separately so you can see
the characteristics and the power
but other times you just use sort of an
abstract queue for both of them but
let's say you're going to have a
superscript so it's going to five raised
to three
can we do that here
can make an example please yes
five five comma three
okay now we say that so this thing here
yep
okay that's what it looks like
but
the true version of this is f sub five
to the three correct right right now the
other notation that's sometimes used is
is brackets isn't it or parens well for
Gower Fields it's parents it's GF
you know yes
to whatever
yeah go ahead I I'm trying to trying to
think so right you use brackets for
polynomial for polynomial rings and then
if you're
sorry I'm just thinking out loud I'm not
sure I have a strong opinion about
uh about the parentheses there but yeah
yes this is the common usage okay
but for the F case it's usually a
subscript right
f it usually is a subscript yes yes okay
so but we're already down in the
subscript area here exactly
and this thing is just unbelievably ugly
yeah
did you just use the standard item there
or what okay I mean that's not a custom
written item at all
it's it's some it's slightly custom
written it's basically the the code
assist uh
uh drop down sort of
you know resized and simplified a bit to
flow into
uh uh you know the the this this size
area
right so right if you if you do you know
plot and then you click on the little
thing to to show
um
the templates I think that's what you'll
see
I think that you're already magnified it
Stephen because I think the next row
there is more like the normal size yeah
yeah yeah yeah right
yeah
225 anyway okay so what can we do here
right
so we need something which is clickable
that allows you to see the field that
the thing is in
but do you need to see it explicitly all
the time
could you I mean because it's gonna be
if you have many elements up there like
even on your screen right now how many
times are you gonna repeat the same
information I know I know I know I
realize
so and the angle brackets are repeating
things as well and so
I think
the other point I mean I mean that
that's could be very large this number
could be very large right
when it's right when it's very large we
replace it with p
why is it P it should be Q because it
could be P to the it doesn't have to be
a prime it can be a prime yes it does
that's because separately
right yeah if we show you put the
exponent separately so it's p cubed or
something right
okay
can I say again what I was saying I
think we should replace this thing with
essentially a tiny f
okay and I think that that's better then
it's constant size right yeah but but
then we have a way of indicating this is
what I was saying before we have a way
of indicating in the app we just say F
in some kind of boxy thing and then a
five so it's not F subscript five it's
box F5
oh do you understand what I'm saying I
think so you understand me do you
understand I do yeah I'm mocking as you
talk okay I've got a couple of cases we
could look at go ahead and chat yeah can
you just grab sharing cannot scare Gene
well I think you're sharing still I
can't share yet okay go for it yeah
okay so bottom
it's original that's just the boxed
version with a like icon that's the
right size but I thought it was weird
just to float this anyway so it's
contained and that's
that's what you were talking about I
think yeah with an opener plus the five
could you magnify yeah I can't really
see that there's an opener there
oh I see so that's the okay now that now
that I see that I I I I understand what
Stephen is saying I wasn't really
following before can you make that a
double struck F instead of the of the f
I'd have to grab it from somewhere uh
just do a DS Escape DSF Diaz capital F
obviously but
oh
Escape DS come to left
and you might want to magnify that a bit
how many of us the down thingy thingy
that's roughly it yeah good magnify
again
no I really like that I I think and I
think that is uh I mean what I what I
put in the Prototype build was the best
of the you know five versions I created
but that one is clearly Superior to all
of them uh I guess you have a job for a
reason chair okay good
um
okay so then when it's superscript when
the five superscripts that box will get
a little taller yeah I don't think that
will go and I don't think that will be
too bad
exactly and we'll just uh you know we'll
keep the f a fix tight and I'll just
make it centered you're right Jeremy
could you try one more thing could you
try making that doubling that Chevron
there instead of the V I worry it's
going to look like a V
and the background color there is what I
just sort of used primary colors to
guess what the
color of to a standard well I'll get it
to a standard we use but that looks very
close to a standard I've seen
right I I I use primary colors on the uh
on the code assist pop-up
so
um it's it's gonna I'll have to get this
rendered as actual font this is really
faked yeah okay
let's just let's see what that looks
like
yeah it's gonna look better with a
double yep yeah absolutely
um
okay we're gonna have a solution here
great well um
okay
uh
if I can bring up one more point if you
in your finite field of five comma three
if you could make chain replace the five
with you know uh
next prime of 10 to the one hundred
okay
and then in this case here
right
right and what what I'm looking at at
that you know where we sh what we're
doing there is we're showing the first
10 digits in the last 10 digits and then
the number of missing digits and I'm
starting to think that 10 on either side
is too much
I agree with you I don't think anybody
cares
right I mean five
exactly that all right that's exactly
what I was suggesting before you showed
up so okay and this I think is fine too
yep
I don't quite know why oh I see planet
field element fine okay good stuff but
was that everything we needed Jeremy for
we don't need him for any of the uh of
the um structured Matrix stuff that
doesn't have any kind of weird
representation no okay right we're not
introducing any new structured types in
this version yes
so yes we are right then he might
well but don't do they have iconography
or not well there'll be summary boxes I
guess the only thing that'll be up to
discussion is the
um
right it's the icon but
well right so do we have those or not
here
to discuss
guys should be yeah yes there should be
there okay so uh
new structured matrices identity Matrix
diagonal matrix I'm sorry I'm sorry so
where do I see these
can I can I see them and yes reference
page
okay which which page just tell me where
identity Matrix identity Matrix new
probably is that right yes even Target
structure has some examples
we have identity Matrix is already a
matrix so I don't understand what this
is
what are you doing here what is this I
don't understand oh okay so the big let
me then recap the big picture
so there are three kinds of matrices
broadly speaking here it's like dense
sparse and structured
okay we have a bunch of Matrix
Constructors that construct structured
matrices some were introduced early
because you know like identity Matrix
probably in version one
and so if you do identity Matrix 10 to
the 100
and see what you get back
um
what's that I just got that oh no sorry
okay right try you know and and do that
for something big okay
and raise to four is the roughly the
cutoff
you don't need the option then
why was it blue before
because that was Data driven
yeah oh I don't know why the um why the
cutoff is so low uh that then 10 to the
second but well it's 100 by 100 it's ten
thousand still seems awfully low
yeah
but yeah and I see he had I see John
hasn't put in sort of custom generic
icons right so for existing
structured arrays we you know we'll have
a based on each type we'll have sort of
a generic icon which clearly is missing
here that's the I don't know what
generic icon to put so I'm putting in
one for structured matrices icon I'm
sorry what are you saying this is not
another confusion like we cut off the G
from the GS thing no no no so right so
every time you write the structured
array framework is a whole framework
now when you define your own type you
can you can Define both a data-driven
icon and a generic icon
for that particular type okay yep yep
now what that icon is is not that's the
generic icon when you haven't specified
a specific generic icon for your
particular type which I think is an
oversight on John's part I mean it's
easy to fix
but okay all right so that we found a
mistake so let's fix it but do you have
the icons for the generic icons for each
of the each of the Matrix types
okay so where are they
who has them
but we don't we haven't made a table
right here for you so you have to go to
online I understand so I'm not going to
be able to do it right now but I'm just
saying somebody needs to look at these
sure I I will make sure to review that
with Jen and and make sure that time or
somebody from design okay yeah we'll
pull them out we'll look at them
specifically I I also don't know what
the cutoff range is for it
that we need to look at but but back to
another Point Stephen apart from the
icon
uh
yeah it should just behave like a matrix
okay yep
um
yes go ahead yeah so so the big picture
is that we are steadily increasing the
number and types of structured arrays
and for right now there are matrices all
the way
but
what they enable us to do is to
represent very efficiently the
operations on these so not everything
will be faster but many things will be
dramatically faster like insane that's
not good
that input form is not good whenever you
have an input form that has a backtick
you know a context in it that's not a
good thing
what should that be
I mean that that is the context we've
used since Version 9 for all structured
arrays
right if you look at symmetris array it
has the same symbol in it which maybe
that's an argument that structured data
needs to be moved to system but I don't
think right structured data indicates
that this is the specific oh we can't
use the name structured data
okay so yeah I agree agreed
uh
so I mean I I'm not look I mean this is
not the most heinous thing but it's not
good what you see here
or all of the cases where
the input form I mean look we have this
issue with graph and things like that
where the input form is full of cruddy
stuff
right and we also have that with you
know like uh interpolating function and
I know so one of these days we should go
through and try and clean that up but
probably today is not the day so that
isn't probably an LCC discussion about
something
um
um okay but that's for another day
okay so you have this notion of Target
structure right so we have some
Constructors to reintroduce long time
ago
uh
uh you know
yeah but but more like diagonal matrix
and Fourier Matrix Matrix okay
okay we also have Matrix decompositions
the whole the sole purpose of a matrix
decomposition is to decoup decompose it
into structured matrices
yeah um and so this enables us to
actually represent them as structured
matrices and be able to leverage that
and now the question is how do we
transition over from the outputs that we
have generated to these
and so you suggested last time we did
this that we should have a structured
uh structured array Target structure
option
and so we've added in Target structure
options everywhere
in many places you can see the places
where we've done it and then the
question is one thing that I think is
important
that gives you control for what you want
but most of the time you probably don't
want control so I think the automatic
setting is actually going to be quite
important
yes you know like for identity matrix
it's perfectly fine to return you know a
list type thing for small dimensions
but it's quite unacceptable to do that
when you have sort of you know a hundred
thousand by a hundred thousand Matrix
it was it will more or less just kill
your system yeah yeah right but I mean
we have many many cases where we have a
dollar Max blah blah blah thing
yeah we have but but I I don't think I
mean we don't want a dollar one for each
one of these matrices no I know I know
so we want them we can't have a one
really I would think so it's just memory
size
you know dollar Max
you know I don't know what normal
array normal Matrix
you know byte count or something
and if it's going to go above that it
uses the structured form
well I think that you want to use it
long before you kind of run into memory
problems no I I understand that I
understand you want to do that so well
whatever I mean but we have examples of
this what are the examples we have a a
all sorts of dollar Max whatever they
are sure yeah
right although I mean what we normally
have are you know things you can't go
beyond right I mean uh the max thing so
like there's
um before you Auto shorten so I mean
like the goodness
children okay well that well that that's
a recent thing that's you can't go
beyond
um you can't go beyond that's a it
aligns when you go beyond right
um right but basically you know Max
extra Precision is right it will just
stop when it hits that right I get it I
get it I'm suggesting that rather than
having a gazillion different settings
that we have something because the main
issue is when's it going to become too
inefficient when's it going to become
too big
is that right Roger yeah
now so when's it going to become to an
efficient
is it reasonable
I mean
you know dollar Max explicit Matrix
elements or something that's not the
right name but you get what I'm saying
if it's going to be more than
a million Matrix elements let's say
more than you tell me right well
I mean I guess Roger can correct me if
I'm mistaken in what I'm about to say
but I believe that you know part of the
issue is not just the memory size but
how expensive it is to compute
explicitly all of those elements fair
enough yeah yeah that's the real issue
so so you know it
yeah it's the the algorithms are like
arbitrarily much faster because they're
as important I guess I get it
but clearly if it's you know round
numbers if it's going to take a second
of CPU time it's gonna matter
but it's going to take you know well I'm
thinking that you rarely want sort of
the explicit list when you're you know
above 10 by 10 matrices it's like what
are you gonna do I don't agree with you
that's a mistake
I've used it a million times there are
all kinds of things where I'm mapping
over elements and things does map work
correctly over structures
absolutely okay does
I mean pattern matching will not work
but uh yeah anything in the map sort of
evaluation
uh thing should should work correctly
and if it's not then that's a bug we
haven't discovered yet
okay
right I mean let me just algorithm I've
been using this since version
what
I'm just reminding you that we've been
using these for symmetry this framework
for symmetrized arrays
very few people have been using some
trust array mechanism
okay what about what about quantity
array
what has happened to the future of a
raise project the array what is it
called the um
yeah
the data container yes
uh so well maybe Roger should speak but
I know Rob has been working very hard on
that and okay good okay I didn't make it
for this version but it's hard it needs
to be full it it there are many working
moving parts to get it all live the part
that Rob has been working on is
convergent just nicely but the other
supporting roles need to be okay I mean
that's a very important thing I agreed
yes and how does that relate to all of
this stuff how would that change your if
these things could throw themselves into
Data containers would that affect your
comments no not really
okay
all right so you think you might have a
heuristic for you know like a Hilbert
Matrix is more wild in terms of what it
has in it than an identity Matrix sure
absolutely
and so we could vary it by
um
by type which is what we have right now
but I don't feel that we've tuned the
numbers yet okay fine
then are we going to have okay so that's
an automatic setting Target structure
are automatic presumably right right
so and obviously you can have a a um
uh
the default I mean okay
so what is the question so is the
question how do you Bank switch these
things to I can't imagine people no I I
kind of want to bring up we've
implemented this suggestion
we've been spreading out and sort of
adding additional structure Matrix type
that also have fast algorithms not just
like a summary box the big thing is the
the algorithms and stuff behind the
scenes yep
yeah we've implemented this we we didn't
think about automatic back then but it
came up as an obvious thing that you
want so you don't typically have to deal
with it yeah right but we have a manual
override if you want to deal with it
so I'm saying you can set it since it's
an option I think target structure Arrow
none should be equivalent to dense
okay
okay none okay yeah fine that looks so
good
okay but so so and we're missing we need
a few more types and we can get sort of
all of our decompositions to return the
full Suite of structured arrays
okay so one Su is if I do Lu
decomposition
do you return structured upper and lower
triangular matrices or at all times
right is that right no so this one also
has the target structure
you know I understand that I'm saying Lu
decomposition
yeah does Lu decomposition really want
because if you're bothering to do that
you're probably doing it because you you
know it's an efficiency hack so
therefore the suggestion would be it'll
always do it yeah value decomposition
uh
[Music]
let me tell you why that's a good idea
in my opinion because
among other things then you'll see LED
composition okay great I see a matrix
which is explicitly upper triangular
lower triangular and maybe I'm wrong
Maybe I'm Wrong well there's a major
compatibility issue there because right
now
uh Lu decomposition doesn't give you an
upper triangular and a lower triangular
Matrix it gives you a combined Matrix I
see that's horrifying but then in the
future maybe we need another function
that's a slightly differently named
daily decomposition that does give you
the list right so so the last time we
discussed this right we we came up with
second string arguments a second or a
string second arguments that specify you
know do you want a combined Matrix
separate matrices you know structured
unstructured Etc
but this is in place of those arguments
because we don't really want to sprinkle
out a bunch of arguments in these
because we need those argument spaces
for other things rather than that
right so
you know I mean maybe we can say Lu
decomposition list
and that's a new function and it will be
the preferred function
and that would return a list of matrices
do you see what I'm saying
yeah
I mean oh yeah but it's so ugly I mean
this is the one decomposition that is
called list
um
okay basically
yeah well I think there aren't a lot of
pretty Solutions right does using Target
structure to do this means we'll have an
option changing the structure of the
output I know like not right it'll go
from a list of three things to a list
but you know that's just a religious
conviction
no no look look guys guys look
if we have a leave decomposition list
and it returns a list of three matrices
probably by default structured
and we gradually deprecate the thing
that just says Lu decomposition
that's probably okay
if we think it's worth it
I think that having the current LED
composition is kind of a messy nasty
1970s you know pack everything into a
matrix because that's all you can do in
Fortran kind of deal
do you agree with that analysis Roger
yeah but the thing is that what we are
missing
like at that time that was a decent
thing to do if you had
the functions that can take that and do
something which we didn't have
well I understand that so I'm saying Lu
decomposition in its current form is
producing a 1970s fortranesque packed
you know dense Matrix okay yes which is
not what we want
so what we want going forward is
something more like Lu decomposition
list which returns a list of three make
two matrices the upper triangular and
the lower triangular lower triangular
and upper triangular right and probably
a permutation
of the Matrix to the structural maybe
it's maybe we need a different name here
I don't know the LED decomposition let's
just write well it's something else but
some other name that Returns the thing
we actually want now people you know
people often refer to this as the PLU
decomposition
okay that's really confusing to have PLU
decomposition do something fundamentally
different than id2 composition I think
we'd be better off saying LED
composition list where Lu decomposition
is defined as the packed Matrix that you
would find in a 1970s Fortran program
well we could just call it Lu
that would be a new name too I know but
we shouldn't do that
because it's not that important in our
world
my favorite composition list what about
ldu matrices I think that's more common
illum Matrix is very calm I mean I see
that being referred to elsewhere
Lu matrices yes that's okay that would
be okay to me yeah I think that looks
and this is a major issue for the
lineage now I really don't want to do it
now I mean we're not going to do it in
the longer discussion we're not going to
do it in 13-3 okay right not for
thirteen three
for 13 3 we're not going to change very
much what led composition returns
yeah unless it's to return a structured
Matrix which is fine but it's not going
to return a list of three matrices
am I making sense
there's no way to do that so we
shouldn't try
do you agree sure
but for the next version It's either Lu
matrices or something else like that
that is going to do the right thing
yes everybody okay with this yes all
right so now the only question is Bank
switching Target structure are automatic
every one of these you will have some
setting for Target structure or
automatic
yeah
um
and we already have that in sparse
arrays that we generate automatically in
certain cases right
uh I don't think yeah yes we have plenty
of cases
well we have cases where we generate
sparsaries by default but I don't think
it's yeah no no we have ones where it
says dependent because I've noticed them
I've forgotten what they are maybe some
graph ones I'm not sure
but okay but so the question is how does
the bank switching work given that the
automatic setting is set differently for
different you know Hilbert Matrix goes
to the structured representation at a
lower size than an identity Matrix
presumably am I correct
yes
okay
so
how do we want to do overall Bank
switching of Target structure
the moment you got something very low
level like a set system options but yeah
I mean I'm just noticing that that's
useful but I'm just saying that would be
a starting point to have okay I think
that the right way to do it
I mean we could probably survive for a
version without having to use a way to
without having a bank way to set it if
you understand what I'm saying yeah
but I think what we should be doing is
probably
something like a dollar Target structure
rules
and then each one could be
you know in dollar Target structure
rules if it's an association it will
give the the result for lower
triangularize it's this
and maybe I mean that's a suggestion for
how to do it
right it can either be
you know a single value or an
association and then
right if it's a value you've done it for
everything and if it's an association
you can control each one
right
and maybe we allow blank as a default
value in the association for all others
something like that I mean we're not
ready we can't figure this out but that
would be a direction to go in for this
it seems to me we can then we can
explore that and then and then I mean
I'm happy with some well we can't have
identity Matrix be experimental
obviously but no so right so so I mean
my point is presumably the the break-off
breakover points
well okay here's another point
maybe when you write code and you say
lower triangularizer blah Target
structure Arrow well I mean it would be
a I see then you could just have if size
of Matrix greater than whatever
I mean you could at least have a
function Target structure Arrow or
function and the function could be given
the dimensions
are making sense
the return value of dimensions a list
right
but I think I mean
the way I thought about this is that
most of the time you're not going to
want to control it this kind of special
cases where you even want to touch I
agree
oh and in that case
you wanted to
quote do the right thing
and what I think is is a normal case
because of a legacy is that for small
matrices be explicit like we have been
absolutely and for big matrices yes
go to structure question is where's the
break point right yeah and I would make
the break point and this version I would
I would I would ER on the side of making
the breakpoint at a larger place so we
don't get a lot of people being confused
and then after we have controls we can
make the breakpoint be lower and lower
that's not unreasonable
okay but in terms of of setting the
break point I think what should be fed
to the setter is the dimensions of the
Matrix
and I'm partly saying that because I
think when you say that like what's the
setter I mean we
in the future would be the dollar you
know dollar Max Target structure
whatever it is thing
the dollar Target structure selector
dollar Target structure rules
see what I'm saying it's okay for the
few for this future dollar yeah such
yeah okay yes and I mean that could say
dollar I mean I not very good Syntax for
right now but dollar Target structure
rules
equals a thousand could mean if the
total number of elements in The Matrix
is more than a thousand go to plan B
that makes sense
otherwise state plan A
all right I think we've got something
we can we can evolve a few do you like
the name Target structure
is that what we've discussed last time
that is what we discussed last time I
think and it's consistent okay to me
it's like this target device Target
whatever right we also use like Target
units for in the plotting functions when
we want to convert the axes so it sounds
reasonable
yeah and it's normally if something
doesn't fit you continually feel that
it's the wrong name and it's not been
the case here it's been you kind of get
used to it and it's like yeah I think
it's reasonable okay all right
um let's just continue here okay oh my
God we're we're appelling it up yes the
the remaining uh three F to F3 F4
um what kind of improvements
for for Apple F1
I know does the double sign
yeah but they're all the same in terms
of uh definition in the region of
convergence the difference is only that
we have uh now the new functions which
were missing early on so the f2s come
from to some extent from qft from
Quantum field Theory I mean that's where
they demonstrated recently
so there's more
f1234 what are they I mean that that
multivariate hyper geometric functions
is that right right so they have a
primary definition in terms of a
bivariate hypergeometric series yes they
all satisfy a horn system a partial
differential equations which are given
in there respective Pages
the numerical evaluation that primary
series have a bounded region of
convergence which is displayed there now
the question is how continuation Works
yep so F1 continuation
was pretty good it had some gaps I think
we filled most of those gaps now okay F2
have
uh quite a lot of continuations
a different hypergeometric series from
F1 yes yes they're all different okay
they're all different
um
it's just when Monsieur Apel happened to
Define them is that right or what do the
one two three four mean
yeah I think uh these different special
cases of a particular double
hypergeometric series the factorial
Series so
okay yeah
I mean they reduced to the
hypergeometrics uh the single
hypergeometrics in on the boundary like
you know when either X or Y 0 so that's
discussed in the notes for each of them
separately what the reduction is yep
so in a sense you have an initial value
problem for the system for the speed is
which you
in principle should be able to solve but
it's very hard
okay
um
our our numerical continuations for the
F3 and F4
are not there that's what I'm saying
they they are there for the when the
series converges okay I get it okay
yeah we didn't continue outside the
units still go wherever the series
converges yes
yes yeah it's partial it's not complete
it's very very okay
what I mean other than the magnificence
of this what else do we have to discuss
about this nothing but we can we can
continue to discuss the magnificence
it's just been requested for so long
that no I know it has I know F2 has been
like I've heard about F2 from like over
years okay when we put this out I have
to remember to send I have to see
whether I can look in my email and find
who's asked for F2 because people have
asked for it
um
okay so yeah that's cool let me just
look up right now
oh boy
yeah there's people who asked for it all
right if somebody can remind me when we
get this finished that we somebody we
should do a troll and just send you know
surprise a pal F2 is that has arrived
now
I remember when we did the matu
functions there were a whole bunch of
people very excited to see those arrive
so hopefully we'll get that same
excitement here
um
magnificent lots of books that's great
and hopefully that will dovetail with
our various llm based education
initiatives which are also coming along
and we'll be able to yes make use of the
books as content for those that will be
really good
um all right what else do we need to
discuss here I'd love to go to another
meeting to which I'm forward I think
that this covers it Stephen I think that
means we're done with Calculus and
Altima tourists and and you had another
meeting that was that had to be moved
for machine learning right
I see one scheduled for tomorrow
okay is that uh I what did we have to
cover there I've forgotten
do you remember
I'm well
right now it's a little bit
I don't think we finished because but
it's also the thing and what happens
with llm tools now in the relationship
to what we ship but maybe that's not a
topic for that
well I mean
that's complicated
okay I mean there's a lot of motion
there right right
um
okay all right thanks a lot guys good
stuff thank you see you later bye